[Music]
so how fast is Godzilla and what are the
fastest and slowest Godzilla
incarations here in this video we will
assess all the different Godzillas well
the ones seen in movies and we will also
put the show of Godzillas in one entry
and do the same with the hyay Godzilla
and we won't include his swimming speeds
which is constantly set at around 35
knots so let's get to the list at number
13 is Godzilla minus one surprisingly
the newest Godzilla is in fact the
slowest and the fact that we can say
that is because of a scene of him
walking in Ginza which is a district in
the larger Tokyo metropolitan area and
there we could see people running away
from his STS and there were many that
managed to escape and outrun the monster
therefore in any case this shows that
Godzilla here is only as fast on land as
the fastest human which is roughly 20 M
hour or 32 km/
hour number 12 Godzilla SOS also known
as kirio Goji he was a malevolent force
of natural destruction even though he is
powerful and terrifying he was not shown
to be moving at a great speed in the
entirety of the movie he had a gradual
walking pace that was almost the same or
a bit faster than Godzilla minus one so
that would mean he was just a bit
faster number 11 gmk Godzilla unlike
other interpretations of the character
this Godzilla is a supernatural entity
inhabited by the Restless Souls of those
killed in the Pacific Theater during
World War II here in this movie he was
seen having a similar speed to SOS all
the other Millennium variants he walks
and he Stomps but he was never seen
running or dashing forth and does he is
the same in speed as the previous
entry number 10 Gods leted to 2000 this
is the first incarnation of the
character to appear in the Millennium
ERA this Godzilla first appeared
sometime after the original Godzilla
demise in 1954 and he continually
menaced Japan over the years just like
the others in this list before him he
had a similar walking pace although with
a bit of a faster frequency between
steps and he was never seen running or
dashing forth therefore we would put his
speed at around 40 km/ hour or 25 M an
hour number nine Shin Godzilla while
Shin Godzilla's second form and the
third form were relatively more agile on
land clocking in at speeds of over 50 m
hour the fourth form which is the main
one in Focus right here had slow strides
kind of like the previous ones but since
he was taller like twice the height and
had longer legs therefore his speed here
would also be slightly faster we would
estimate him walking with a pace of 20
to 30 m hour or around 32 to 48 kmph
speed number eight Godzilla Earth now
this is the biggest Godzilla Incarnation
till date and probably withh hold the
title for a very long time Godzilla
Earth was seen to be very slow and had a
very lazy Pace it took him half the
movie of Mecha Godzilla City to get from
one place to another yet the distance
was vast to begin with and even though
he had a pace that was twice slower than
Shen Godzilla his size however which is
three times means that he still covers
more ground thus we would put him at
more than 30 m hour or almost 50 km per
hour number seven heay Godzilla so this
variant here despite being outclassed
and speed by his arrivals in the H
period was still able to fight to the
end and at times get a hold of the
nimbler gidora and destoya when you
watch the movies you would see Godzilla
here having a pace that is more than
twice that of shin Godzilla despite
being smaller than him well just a bit
so therefore with this reasoning he
would be less than twice faster than
Shin or around 40 m an hour or if we
want to convert it into metric system 64
km/ hour number six Godzilla Ultima just
like Shen Godzilla Godzilla singular
point also had several different forms
that evolved within the show in a matter
of days his aquarist form was fast
underwater but as we said before we will
only cover speed on or Overland also
like shin the ultimate form was seen to
be slow and cumbersome barely covering
any distance but when he was battling
Jet Jaguar in the final episode we get
to see him do a sudden charge at the
robots catching it off God and this is
his speed record in the anime we
estimate this sudden Dash to be roughly
between 50 to 80 M hour or around 80 to
130 km per
hour number five Godzilla final Wars the
final war stop G was a beast in speed
his normal walking speed was easily
three or four strides faster than most
other Godzillas the scene that sets his
speed record was when he was fighting
with Monster X when they both charged at
each other Godzilla had strides that
almost covered his body size in just a
second M knew that this Godzilla was 100
m or 328 ft tall therefore that would
put his speed at somewhere between 150
to 200 mph or 240 to 320 km/ hour number
four TriStar Godzilla this Godzilla here
looked more like a dinosaur than a Kaiju
but nevertheless we will include him
here the 1998 Godzilla was very fast and
agile possessing a land speed of over
300 mil an hour or 480 km/ hour this
speed was showcased in the movie when he
was able to outrun multiple squadrons of
ah64 Apache Longbow helicopters and
despite being in point blank range he
was also able to avoid and Dodge
missiles launched at him with ease
number three the kotm and GVK Godzilla
Godzilla of the monsterverse is indeed a
heavy dude he walks around weighing
100,000 tons but don't let that fool you
in king of the monsters and in Godzilla
versus gong when he was charging against
Monster Zero and Mecha Godzilla
respectively his speed was over the top
even if it doesn't look like it he was
able to cover more than his own body
height which is 120 m in less than a
second that when extrapolated puts his
speed between 300 and 350 M an hour or
between 480 and 560 km/
hour number two gxk the new Empire
Godzilla in the trailer of gxk we saw
the new pinkzilla and it seems to be
larger and more deadli looking in the
final scenes we get to witness him
running or charging for an an extended
period of time alongside Kong against an
unknown enemy in that scene it was clear
that he was faster than his earlier GVK
form and even Kong was trying to keep up
with him he was running like an Apollo
Creed with Kong as Rocky Balbo behind
him here we can estimate him to have a
faster speed than GVK so a top running
speed of easily more than 400 mph or
over 640 km per hour number one the
shower Godzilla surprising the top speed
goes to the showa era Godzilla not the
original but the later goofy
incarnations take for example his flying
kick attack with his size of 50 m or 65
ft that attack speed would clock him at
more than 250 mph or 4 kmph but that's
not the absolute limit the speed record
was funny enough set by him when he flew
across the sky using his Atomic breath
as a propellant it was stated that there
he flew past the speed of sound which
means at least Mark 1 or 740 M an hour
or in the metric system 1200 km per hour
so those are the slowest to the fastest
Godzillas ranked in this list now if you
like this video then watch this other
one as well and do check out our Channel
as we might have things that you haven't
seen before like subscribe and we'll see
you in the next video take care
fam